Hello, today is April 21st in the
year 2023.
I'm Karen Herman and I am
delighted to be interviewing Deb
Goodkin for the Free and Open
Source Stories Digital Archive.
So welcome and thank you so much
for doing this.
I'm very excited to be doing this
with you today.
And we're going to start right
from the beginning, which is when
and where were you born?
Oh, well, I was born in Hollywood,
California.
And I was born in 1961.
And where did you grow up?
So I grew up in Southern
California.
And so half my childhood was in
Los Angeles.
And then we moved to San Diego,
which was great.
And, and lived there until I
graduated from college.
What did your parents do?
So my dad, it was always really
hard to understand what he did.
None of us kids really interested
in it, not like he was in the CIA
or anything.
But he, he basically was in real
estate, but helping large
developers develop, like larger
communities.
And so he did that, as long as I
knew, and was like, sort of known
as an expert in that.
And I worked for him when I was in
high school, when I was in
college, and he actually thought I
would take over the business from
him.
And my mom worked until she had
kids.
And she wanted to be a doctor, and
she would have been a great
doctor, but she was a
bacteriologist.
And a lot of it was just because
of the times.
And do you have any brothers or
sisters?
I have two older brothers.
And what kind of kid were you?
Um, Um, I guess if I think about
that, I, um, I don't know if it
was because I had brothers, but I
was very outdoorsy.
And I always remember us kids just
playing outside all the time.
And I think growing up in Southern
California, I mean, the weather
was always beautiful.
And so you could do that.
And we had a swimming pool at
home.
And so we in the summers, we swam.
And I always remember my oldest
brother was into filming.
So he had this old camera, and
then he would set us up, we would
do like war scenes, all sorts of
things that we would play
together.
And so I think as a kid, I would
have been referred to as a tomboy.
But really, I mean, to me, that's
just like being a kid, just being,
you know, curious and active.
And, because when one of my
brothers was much older than me,
he would take me backpacking and
river rafting and things like
that.
So, so it was a good childhood.
Did you have any idea what you
wanted to be when you grew up?
I wanted.. there are a lot of
things I wanted to be.
And I think that's what made it
hard.
And, and my parents, they never
encouraged me to be anything, but
they never limited it.
So they never made me feel like
there was anything I couldn't do.
So I mean, I went from wanting to
be an astronaut to a veterinarian
to, you know, I thought about
being a doctor.
So, so, you know, so, so it was
nice being able to think about it
or knowing I had those options.
And but, but it took time
narrowing down, you know, where,
where I thought I should go.
Did, did you have any interest in
computing or computers as a kid?
So, um, we didn't have a computer
when I was growing up.
So that was before home computers.
And so I really, the only thing I
knew about computers was really
the word processors, which were
fancy typewriters.
And because my dad was also a
writer, we had one at home.
And so that was pretty novel.
And but, but I didn't grow up with
computers.
So I didn't know anything, I
really didn't know anything about
them.
And, and so it really wasn't until
I went to college that I was
exposed to computers.
So really, before that, I mean,
part of my growing up, and maybe
because I had brothers too, I
built a lot of things, I was
really into, like building models,
and we would build like, model
cars and model airplanes and
things like that.
So I've always enjoyed that
building things.
And where did you go to college?
I went to University of California
in San Diego, and for my
undergrad, and then I went to
University of Santa Clara, up in
Santa Clara, California.
And what did you study?
So for my undergrad, it was
computer engineering, which was,
at that time, it was part computer
science and part electrical
engineering.
And then for my master's degree, I
got a master's in electrical
engineering.
It's interesting, because you said
that you really didn't have, you
didn't know anything about
computers till you got to college.
How did you then decide to major
in it?
Yeah, I mean, that's a really good
question.
Because when I started college,
actually, I was focused more on
business, because like I said,
before, the plan was really for me
to take over my dad's business.
But it wasn't something I was
really interested in.
And my mom actually helped me try
to figure out what I was good at.
And I grew up thinking, never
thinking I was good at math, but
my mom would always tell me how
she was good at math.
I don't even know why it would
come up.
But I knew that I knew my mom was
good at math.
And so I realized that I was also
very good at math.
And so in doing like an assessment
test at that time, computer
science, and engineering actually
came up as a strength.
And I thought, you know what, I,
this would be a great major,
because I could get a job.
And so that was really why I went
in that direction.
And was there something specific
that you studied?
Um, Um, well, actually, I was
really, so in the computer
engineering, you get a lot of, you
know, computer science theory, and
like understanding algorithms, and
you learn a lot of different
programming languages from, we
actually started with punch cards,
just to check them out.
So I mean, at that time, you had
Pascal and Fortran and BASIC.
And we did, we wrote an assembly
language, we wrote compilers, so a
lot of software development, and
as well as understanding theory,
but also electrical engineering
side, so circuits and in all in
the typical types of classes that
you would get in electrical
engineering, I took math all four
years, just because, as an
elective, just because I was good
at it.
And, and so I made sure I always
took a math class.
And so then you went to graduate
school.
Again, was there was there
something that you wanted to do
specifically, at that point?
So, so I didn't plan to go to grad
school after I graduated.
When I joined IBM, it was a time
when they actually were hiring a
lot of new college graduates.
And so, so when I started IBM, and
we had, I don't know how many,
maybe there's 10, eight or 10 of
us that were all new, and, and IBM
offered to pay for your tuition to
go to grad school.
So we all considered doing it.
And the choice really was between
Stanford and University of Santa
Clara, because both universities
were right there.
And I actually chose University of
Santa Clara, because they had a
new storage focus.
So it was the first time any
university that I knew of was
actually teaching about storage
devices and that type of
technology, which made sense,
because IBM, so I worked for IBM,
that's what what we did there.
And, and so and actually, Santa
Clara Valley was growing into sort
of a storage focused area.
So, so that was my focus, even
though it was electrical
engineering.
And, and it was really just, you
know, to have that degree under my
belt, and the fact that IBM paid
for it.
And actually, you could finish
your last quarter semester as a
full time student, and you still
get got your salary at the time.
So it was a pretty good deal.
Well, and where were the offices
at IBM?
They're in South San Jose.
And that campus is gone.
When I go there, I don't, I don't
even recognize anything anymore.
It was a large campus, though.
And you were working with storage?
I was working storage.
Yeah, I, so it's not like now
where you have a disk drive on
your desk, and you actually see
it.
They were in big cabinets in on
the, in the computer rooms, and in
those air conditioned rooms.
And so rarely would I actually go
and look at it.
But so I worked on a, you know, a
small component of, of the storage
device.
And I also, so I did some
firmware, or we called it
microcode there, and, and also
went into hardware development,
doing logic design.
And so, so I focused on the ECC,
the error correct, error
correction code.
And, and that was a really nice
opportunity, because one of the
main architects of ECC, of the ECC
there at IBM was working in our
group, and I got to work under,
under him.
And so I learned a lot.
So it was a great opportunity.
What year was that?
Oh, I don't know.
That was, so I joined IBM in 1984.
Okay.
And I worked for them for like
three years, maybe.
What was the state of storage at
that time?
So different?
So, um, storage.
So I don't know, I don't remember
how much you could store on those
large storage devices.
But, um, I mean, these were
storage devices storage devices
for large computers.
So companies like, you know, like
HP would use, well, they had their
own computers.
But, you know, basically, you, the
the the the customer would have
like an IBM 360 computer, which is
also a big cabinet.
And then they would have the
storage that would go with it.
When I was at IBM, the first PCs
were coming out.
And so, so we actually got those
to use for development.
And the first PC had a floppy
drive, I don't think we had any
hard storage on it.
But I always remember getting my
first disk drive that was five
megabytes, which is nothing now.
It was so much and then it doubled
to we went to 10 megabytes.
But, but it was so cool to be able
to have your own computer with
your own storage that you could
save your own files to.
And so the the disk drives we
worked on at IBM, those were 14
inch platters or just, you know,
just size.
And, and so once you had the
personal computer, those were five
and a quarter.
So typically, if you see a disk
drive, then it's it's usually like
the older ones are five and a
quarter.
I don't know your know, if you can
get those anymore.
Nowadays, if you're still getting,
you know, rotational disk, then
it's it's three and a half or two,
two and a half.
So, you know, so they just kept
getting smaller.
And, and larger storage, as you
know, now, they're in the
terabytes.
How long were you there at IBM?
I think I was there for three
years.
So, so it wasn't, it wasn't real
long.
And at that time, you when you
joined IBM, you're a lifer, you
people didn't leave IBM.
And I mean, and they took care of
you.
And so there was really no reason
to leave.
But it's also when Silicon Valley
was just coming alive.
And, and so when you work for IBM,
you were paid the same.
It didn't matter where you, you
lived in San Jose and the whole
Bay Area was a pretty expensive
place to live.
And, and so I thought I could do
better financially.
Another company was one of the
other startups.
And there were quite a few storage
companies starting out in that
area.
And so I went, that's when I, I
left IBM.
And really, that was the time
others started leaving IBM too.
So, so I think it was just how
things were, you know, changing at
the time with, with, you know, the
emergence of this whole Silicon
Valley.
What did you, what was the thing
that you learned the most about at
IBM?
At IBM, it gave me a really good
foundation on how to develop code.
And so you didn't really have like
a hacking mentality then, like you
have now.
And, and, and that's fine, too.
It's just that you really had to
think through, what are you trying
to do?
And then how are you going to do
that?
And then, And then, as like a
junior level engineer, I would
actually, so I'd have to come up
with my plan or my design.
And then you actually had a design
that you hand wrote.
So it wasn't a programming
language yet.
And, and so we actually refer to
it as pseudocode.
And then you would actually meet
with others, your colleagues, and,
and people would review your
design.
And so you wouldn't actually
implement it until it got
approved.
So, so it was a great way to learn
because if someone saw like a hole
in that, or even a, you know, a
better way to do something, you
would learn from that.
And so taking that time to think
through, you know, what, really,
what are you trying to achieve?
And then how can you get there?
I, that was a good skill to have,
and philosophy to have.
Also working with others to learn
how to collaborate with others.
I mean, you learn that in school,
but, but now, you know, you have a
real product.
And, and the way IBM worked back
then, too, is sometimes you had
competing teams.
And so they had the money to fund,
like, similar teams, you didn't
always know it.
And, and so whoever came out with
better product, you know,
basically won.
You didn't look at it like that,
basically, they would cancel your
product, project, and you'd move
on to something else.
So, because things were so new,
back then, too.
So you didn't, there was so much
possibility for innovation.
And so I think that philosophy,
that IBM was able to do that, was
great.
I also learned a lot from my
manager, who happened to be a
female, and her background was
electrical engineering, too.
And she was such a good role model
for me, as well as a lot of the
other people there.
So, so it was a great experience
starting out.
Were there a lot of other women
that you were working with at the
time?
Did you?
So, there were real, I mean, I
would say it was 50-50.
But that group of people that they
hired, the group of college
students that they had hired when
I joined, I almost want to say it
was half and half of, of women and
men.
And, which was really cool,
because it made it so, it made it
just normal.
And we were all, everyone was
really sharp, and came from
different backgrounds in different
schools.
And, but we're all young, and we
came from college.
And so we still wanted to enjoy
ourselves.
And so we actually formed great
relationships with each other,
too, where we would, you know,
we'd go out on Friday nights
together, go dancing and, and
stuff.
So it was really, it was a great
friendship that we all had.
And then, and which, it didn't
carry over to the other companies
I worked at.
So, so it was a really interesting
opportunity.
And in, you know, going forward, I
don't know if that's something
that IBM continued to do.
But it was just happened to be the
timing when I joined that they
were just hiring a bunch of new
people.
Where did you go after IBM?
I went to Mac Store.
And so they're a disk drive
company, they were doing the five
and a quarter inch drives.
And so I didn't do any firmware
for them, I actually joined as the
applications engineer.
And so what that meant was that,
so you have the product, and it
could have been in development,
most time it was in development.
And but I worked with the
customers who wanted to use assist
drives.
And so most of the time, either I
would have those systems of those
companies, or I would actually go
on site and, and basically make
sure that it worked in their
applications.
And then if it didn't, debugging
and, and figuring out or, you
know, working with the engineering
team, what, you know, is it on our
side?
Is it on the customer side?
Do they need to make changes?
And, and so it was really
interesting, because I got to work
with Sun Microsystems, DAC, HP,
NeXT computer, which isn't around
anymore, but that's like where
Wasnik went after Apple.
So that so working with NeXT was
pretty exciting at that time,
because they're pretty cool.
And you were early in Silicon
Valley, that's really when things
are totally booming.
What was that like?
It was just starting.
Yeah, it was just I mean, it's
funny, because I mean, tech, tech
was there.
But it wasn't like the big boom,
which was happening, I think that
was more in the 90s.
But yeah, you had, you had Apple,
and like I said, NeXT.
And so you had these really
innovative companies that were
just starting out and growing.
I mean, HP had been around for a
while, DAC, same thing, but still
working with some some of these,
you know, longtime companies like
DAC versus like, NeXT that came
out with this black computer.
Yeah, no one had done that before.
It was really cool.
It was really innovative.
Sun was pretty well known.
And, and so and so I got to work
with engineers at all those
companies.
And so, so it was really good
exposure, as well as learning,
learning opportunities, and seeing
how other companies worked.
And, and also just really problem
solving, trying to figure out why,
why something doesn't work.
Was there a lot of secrecy, and,
you know, kind of proprietary
knowledge and things like that?
So everything was proprietary,
but, um, but no, it wasn't like
that.
Like, so I think of secrecy, I
think of like Apple, how, how, I
mean, they're still like that.
Really successful.
That's how they work.
So I mean, I came here and think
of whether, you know, did we have
NDAs?
Did I have to worry about that?
I actually don't remember that.
But all of our stuff, like, so all
the code that I wrote, that was
all proprietary code.
And, you know, and it's, I mean,
basically, it was up to us to
update that firm, and it was all
firmware.
And so it resided on the drive.
And so it was up to us to update
that if there were any problems.
Or do you find that collaborative
as well?
Or could you call people from
other companies or things like
that?
Well, it's definitely working with
the other companies was definitely
collaborative, because you wanted,
you wanted it to work.
So you didn't, so you had to work
together.
And there was nothing competitive
about that.
So, so I remember it as just, you
know, friendly, friendly
environment, when, oh, and when I
would meet with when, oh, and when
I would meet with companies,
sometimes, especially like if it's
somewhere totally different, like
I went to Maine.
And so the head engineering
manager there took me on this
little there took me on this
little sightseeing tour with his
wife, and which was, which was so
nice.
And I, and I remember in Alabama,
going to the Space Center, when I
was there, and I can't remember
the company I was working with.
But, but yeah, that's, yeah, you
would have, over time, you'd build
relationships with people.
And so, so that was always fun
when, when you had those
opportunities, too.
And then within the teams, I
always remember, whether it was at
IBM, or Maxstar, or any other, any
of the other jobs, I had that it
was always collaborative, you're
always working together with
other, other folks to create this
product or solve a problem.
And Maxstar, you started to be
more management, right?
You started to manage people as
well.
So Maxstar was the first time,
yeah, I had a, I moved into a
management job.
Yes.
And where did you go from there?
So, so Maxstar actually bought
Miniscribe, which was based in
Colorado.
And, and so I want, at the time, I
wanted to leave California for
various reasons.
And I was really interested in
moving to Colorado.
But at the time, they wouldn't
transfer any engineers to
Miniscribe.
And for various reasons.
And so, since I had started
pursuing that, I thought, well,
okay, let me just look around.
And so I ended up working for a
company called Sirius Logic.
And so that was more, that was a
chip company.
So it was still in storage, but it
was at a different level.
Well, it was at a lower level.
And that I'd been working at
before and I stayed in
applications engineering, but it
was, we were referred to as field
application engineers.
So you worked directly with a
salesperson and you had customers
here in this region, and, and you
actually went on site.
And so typically, you would go to
either help them bring something
up, or if there was a problem, you
would go and help debug it.
And so it was sort of, it was more
like a technical sales role.
So it was, it was really
interesting to see that.
You know, it's just sales is so
different than just engineering.
And it got you to Colorado.
It got me to Colorado.
Yep.
So it got me what I wanted.
It was a good, it was a good
company.
I have to say all the companies I
worked for.
They're great.
And yeah, great experiences.
Yeah, not I mean, it's not wasn't
perfect.
But, but yeah, they're good.
So there I didn't, I didn't last.
I maybe I worked for them for a
year.
I can't remember.
It wasn't, it wasn't long term.
I actually went from there and I
went to work for Connor
peripherals, which is was bought
by Seagate eventually after I
left.
And so Connor peripherals was
founded by these two guys.
And one of the guys actually was
based.
Well, actually, I think they both
were based out here.
But one still was in charge of
this facility and development
center.
And he was still a developer.
And, and so I went back into
firmware.
And, and so and I worked on SCSI
devices, just different computer
interface.
And, and so I had the opportunity
to work with him, which was so
cool.
And, you so cool.
And, you know, and back then, and
maybe this is also different than,
like working on a software project
is that you have a smaller code
set.
And so you don't need a large
group of people to work on it.
So I basically own all the code
that from the computer interface
to the disk drive, to where you
send the, the data off to the
read, write logic.
And hardware.
How is that different from what
came before?
Was it was it completely?
Was it the only way to make that
happen?
Yeah, you mean, in general, on a
distress?
Or?
Yeah.
It was just a larger.
Well, so like at IBM, you have a
lot more circuitry.
So, so when I wrote firmware
there, I was just writing, I wrote
the firmware that just basically
wrote the data to the E squared
prom.
And so it's a really small, small
component of this drive.
Whereas at Connor, I was so you
have a disk drive, disk drive
talks to your computer.
So you have your operating system,
your host, and then it has you
have your file, you want to write
your file, you want to save it to
the desk.
So, so your operating system would
send that file to the disk drive
disk drive.
So you have that interface.
And that's the part that I would
control.
And so and I would take the so you
communicate, you talk back and
forth, take the data.
So data is what you want to
protect.
So you don't want anything
corrupted.
And so and then you, you do
whatever you need to do with it in
the disk drive, and then the read
write code takes it and actually
writes it to, to the media, which
is a lot more complicated.
And you were at how long were you
at Connor?
I was at Connor for I can't
remember, five years, I'd have to,
I'd have to look back at, but you
know, it was basically so caught.
So Connor was, um, I think it was
sort of the changing point in my
career where, um, you know, I
didn't quite like the nine to five
type of life and having to be in
meetings a lot and also judged on
how many hours are you there
actually at the office.
And, um, and so I knew people who
did what I did, but as consultants
or contractors.
And that's when I decided, I like
the idea of being more flexible.
And my skill was needed and
desired.
And there weren't a lot of people
who wrote firmware.
And so I took that chance of
leaving and, and I had a contract
when I left and, and I just
contracted for years.
And, and it was great because I
felt like if people like the work
I was doing, they would hire me
and they would pay me.
And I didn't have to spend a lot
of time, um, in meetings.
It didn't matter what my hours
were during the day.
And because one thing I really
like to do, and I still do this is
I like to start really early.
And then I like to take one to two
hours off, um, before lunch to go
work out.
And I love having that
flexibility.
And so, um, so it was, it was
good.
And I had, um, I contracted for
Sony and Seagate and, uh, Maxdor
and a lot of just different, uh,
disk drive companies.
And is that, and were you doing
that, um, when you, when you, um,
went to the FreeBSD foundation?
Was that?
So I, I, um, I wasn't quite doing
that much anymore.
What I, I have a gap really in my
engineering career.
Cause, uh, when 9/11 happened, um,
it changed, um, well really
affected the economy and, and
companies and, uh, companies, when
they could hire, um, it would be
so hard for them to have a open a
rack that they wouldn't want it to
be full time.
And, and what I was always trying
to do was work part-time and maybe
I would take two contracts, two
part-time ones, or even just work
part-time and cause I had young
kids and that's what I wanted to
do at the time.
And, um, so I found it really
difficult to find work.
And so, um, so I, I took some time
off.
I did, um, jumped in, in and out
of a few types of jobs.
And then, um, and then I took on
the foundation and I did take it
on part-time at the beginning too.
And it was really because they
didn't have probably any money at
the time.
So I saw it as an opportunity.
Okay.
Let's, let's, let's, let's, let's,
let's actually back up a little
bit and talk about that.
How did you first, um, you know,
hear about the FreeBSD foundation
and how did, how were you
connected?
So, um, the FreeBSD foundation, I
didn't know anything about.
And, um, so, uh, my friend had
contacted me and she said, so she
was working at this, um, aerospace
company here in Boulder.
And, um, so I'm here in Boulder,
Colorado.
Um, and she said, I, there's a guy
at my company.
So she worked at an HR and she
said, there's this guy in my
company.
He's running a nonprofit and he's
looking for someone to run it.
And I told him that I had a friend
who is an engineer and looking for
some work.
And so anyway, so she connected us
and that was the first time I had
heard of FreeBSD and the FreeBSD
foundation.
And so, um, so the guy she was
talking about was Justin Gibbs,
who's the founder of the FreeBSD
foundation.
He's here in Boulder and he had
started the foundation, I think it
was about four or five years
before that.
And I bet he was working full
time.
And so it was growing to the point
where he really couldn't run it.
He, and he saw so much potential
for growth that he wanted to find
someone to run the company.
And so, so he went to my friend,
right.
For just for advice on, you know,
how do I find someone?
And, um, and so we met at, had
lunch together and decided that I
was the right person.
And, uh, so, so, you know, it, I,
I always feel like I lucked out in
the timing and the situation and,
um, and it's been, it's been a
great opportunity.
What did you know about the free
and open source world before you
started?
I knew nothing about it, which is
just so weird because I mean, when
I look at the history and stuff,
cause I worked with Unix in the
early days.
So I knew about that, but, um, but
because I was so focused on disk
drives and storage and I worked,
um, on optical storage, it was
very focused what I did.
And firmware is, um, it's almost
at the hardware level.
So you don't even have the bigger
picture of software.
And, um, and so we, none of the
companies I worked at, we never
used open source.
And, uh, so I didn't have any
exposure to it before that.
So, uh, so that was all new and,
and that's what made it so
interesting working for the
foundation because, um, I mean, I
had the engineering background,
but I didn't have operating system
background.
Um, open source didn't, that part
didn't really matter.
Um, but I never worked for a
nonprofit, let alone run a
nonprofit.
So, um, so I was stepping into
this whole new world and, um, and
so it was really a good learning
opportunity.
I mean, you talk about like every
day you have something, maybe not
like fun, right?
Cause it, maybe you're figuring
out like, well, what can we
legally do?
Or, you know, cause I needed to
hire myself and, uh, or employee
myself.
I was the first employee.
And so what does that mean?
What kind of, you know, what kind
of federal and state laws do you
have to follow to have an
employee?
And, uh, you know, so there's so
many little things.
And unfortunately the friend that
I had at this one company that
Justin worked at, um, she actually
gave me advice on, cause since she
was from HR, uh, she could
actually give me a little bit of
advice to, to get started.
Like here, here's, here are the
government sites where you can get
this type of information.
So, uh, so I was always trying to
figure things out.
And, um, and then, um, I, my focus
was really more on FreeBSD as an
operating system and trying to
understand that, understanding,
um, use cases and big companies.
Why are they using FreeBSD and how
are they using it?
And so understanding that over it
being open source.(something
gibberish) Well, that's a really
good question.
Uh, because he, so basically he
saw that, um, that he thought the
engineering side of me would
really help, uh, with project
management.
And so at the time we were really
only funding projects and the
biggest project was, uh, making
sure the Java binaries from Sun,
um, worked on FreeBSD.
And, uh, so he thought I'd step in
and project manage that, which I
did.
That was my first project.
Um, he also thought, I don't know
if I should make this on the
recording or not, but he, he also
thought as a mom that I'd be well
organized to run a company.
And I mean, little did he know, I
really wasn't very organized.
So just cause you're a mom, I
mean, you're automatically an
organized person, but it's, but,
um, but maybe it helped me get a
job.
Did you, did you have, um, did you
have a lot of free reign when you
started?
I I mean, you basically had to
create the whole thing.
Yeah.
I mean, he really wanted me to
just, you know, please just, you
know, let me hand this off to you
and just go with it.
But he was, he was always
available when I had questions
and, um, and so, so that's why, I
mean, it was a good opportunity
because I could do that.
And so some of the stuff was just
administration, like, oh, let's
get a tax exempt, uh,
certification.
So we don't have to pay sales
taxes to just how to, you know,
which we do about taxes.
And then, um, I, I did all of our
accounting and, um, and actually
that was one thing that I used to
do for my dad too was, um, was
accounting.
So I had that, that background.
Um, and so I did that for, for a
really long time for the company
until we really grew.
And, uh, but yeah, he, he was
available to ask questions.
We also had a board of directors
and they were at the time they
were hands on.
So, um, so if you needed someone
to do like review, uh, a proposal
or actually to even write an
article for a newsletter, um, then
it was always a board member that
we do that.
Cause it was just me.
And then, um, and I was learning
from them too.
What, um, you know, what was the
foundations, you know, what are
our long-term goals?
What are we really trying to do?
And we're really defining that as
time went by.
Cause initially it was just to
fund certain projects and, um, oh,
provide travel grants to people to
go to conferences.
And, um, and so then from there,
it's really, um, wasn't so much
like, what do we want to do?
What does the project need?
Cause that's our purpose is to
support the project and the
community.
And so, um, it's a lot of
discussions on that, which was,
um, which was always interesting.
I mean, we still do that.
Talk about, so, so the, the
FreeBSD foundation and then
there's the FreeBSD, how, how does
that work, um, in terms of, you
know, how you work together or, or
don't?
Yeah, we're two totally different
organizations.
And so the FreeBSD project is, uh,
made up of volunteers and, uh,
from around the world and it's not
a legal entity.
And we have the FreeBSD foundation
and, uh, which is a legal entity.
It's, uh, um, here in the US we,
it's, um, based, uh, when the IRS,
um, uh, not certification, but,
um, a definition, um, is this that
we're a 501 C three.
And so there's different types of
nonprofits here.
And so we're for the public good.
And so our whole purpose is to
support the project.
So if FreeBSD went away, then we
would most likely go away because
we wouldn't have a purpose
anymore.
And so there's a lot of
foundations out there that are
umbrella organizations.
And so it means that they have the
foundation and then the project or
multiple projects are under them.
And so when you have it like that,
then you have a lot more control
of the project and I could tell,
basically, uh, direct them and
tell, tell them what to do.
So the way that we work is that I
always, like, if I create an org
chart, I would put a side by side
and we could step in.
And since we're a legal entity, we
could actually sign legal
documents on behalf of the
project.
And, uh, but also, uh, when we see
that there's needs or the project
comes to us with, with needs, um,
then we look at, we have funding
and, um, and so we might be able
to fund a project.
Or, um, or we buy equipment for
the FreeBSD infrastructure.
And so, uh, so basically, uh,
we'll provide resources for the
project.
We also do advocacy.
And, um, so we, uh, travel around
the world and give talks on
FreeBSD.
We'll have, uh, tables at
conferences and we'll promote
FreeBSD.
We provide literature and
educational material and, um, and
things like that.
So, so we're always trying to
promote FreeBSD and, uh, we also
talk to, uh, companies that use
FreeBSD as well as potential users
and, uh, work on like value
propositions and why, why you
should use FreeBSD.
So we're also, we also act as
salespeople for it, even though,
you know, I mean, cause FreeBSD is
a product, it doesn't cost
anything to get it.
Um, but we want to get more people
using it.
So if someone doesn't know what
FreeBSD is, how would you describe
it?
And, you know, what's sort of your
sales pitch for it?
Um, well, usually, I mean, sadly
we'll say, have you heard of Unix?
Cause I mean, not Unix, Linux, uh,
cause most people have heard of
Linux.
And, um, and so we'll say, you
know, it's, it's, uh, it's, it's,
it's, it's a free computer
operating system.
It's based off of, uh, Unix, which
is over 50 years old and, uh, came
out of development out of, uh, out
of Berkeley.
And, um, and it's used on, uh, you
know, you're, you're probably
using FreeBSD right now.
Cause if you watch Netflix, all
those, um, shows and movies are
being streamed off FreeBSD
devices.
And if you're running, if you have
an iPhone, um, iOS and MacOS were
all originally developed off of,
um, BSD and then FreeBSD from
that.
And, oh, and the, the Sony
PlayStation is also FreeBSD based.
So, so once, um, you use examples
of those types of companies that
are using FreeBSD, then people are
like, oh, and so, you know, so
it's, it's a nice way to connect,
uh, FreeBSD to, uh, what they know
or what they're using today.
Cause even with Linux is the same
thing.
It's like, they've heard of it,
but are they running Linux on
their computers?
Yeah, most, most aren't.
So, I mean, we all know windows
and, um, and you know, MacOS.
And then, and then, and then in
terms of the, in terms of the open
source piece of it, um, talk about
that.
Well, so FreeBSD has a really long
history.
Like I was saying, it, um, it
branched off of the original Unix
and, um, and Unix became open
source eventually.
And, um, it's like the real first
unencumbered Unix like operating
system actually came out of
Berkeley and it was called, uh,
386 BSD.
And that was back in the early
eighties.
And so basically Berkeley took
Unix and developed on it.
So some of it was for research.
Um, well, most of it was for
research.
They're being funded by the
government too, to work on it.
And so, you know, the first open
source really was, I think like in
the early fifties, cause when
these large companies like IBM and
Amdahl, when they, uh, so they
came, they developed these
computers.
And so when they'd sell a
computer, that's where they made
their money, not on the operating
system or the software.
So that they actually provided
that too, because also it was to
their benefit to have others make
it work for them.
And then it was more like when
windows came out, maybe it wasn't
windows cause it was DOS.
Um, then you started having,
seeing value in selling software
and then that's when it became
proprietary.
And, um, so, so it had changed
over time.
Right.
So when, um, so when like Berkeley
Unix and then Linux came out and
FreeBSD, um, that was, it was
considered, um, you know,
competitive to windows back then.
Okay.
And talk to me...
So, so I get, so getting back to
like open source, the FreeBSD, um,
I mean, we, so we were really one
of the first open source projects
around.
We weren't the first, but we were
one first open source projects
around.
We weren't the first, but we were
one of the first, um, and largest
and most successful really.
And we're still around and we're
still growing.
So still growing.
So it's not like we're still just,
you know, I mean, we're still,
we're still growing.
I mean, we're getting more still,
I mean, we're getting more users
and, um, you know, more companies
using FreeBSD.
So, so we have a very long history
and, um, and also, and a lot of
open source projects can learn
from, you know, our government
governance model, as well as some
of the things that we did in the
early days to, to make it
successful.
Can you talk about that?
What those things that you did in
the early days?
So, um, some of them were in, and
I wasn't around for these, but,
um, um, like they use a software,
uh, source control, um, version
control, um, back in the early
days where when other projects
done.
Now I did, but he's, I did, that's
something that we did.
But apparently open source
projects did not.
And so it's something we still do
on most projects.
All, all, all of them, most of
them will use Git now.
Um, so that was one thing, a flat,
um, um, a flat development model,
meaning that, um, we, if you
compare, uh, so a lot of, uh,
comparisons happen between FreeBSD
and Linux.
And Linux, you have, um, Linus
Torvalds, who is the one who came
up with Linux and is still the
head person there, and you have a
lieutenant structure.
And so when you make a change, it
has to go up that hierarchy to get
approved and, or reviewed.
And within FreeBSD, it's a flat
structure.
And so you can submit something
and someone within the team will
review and either approve it or
not.
Uh, it doesn't mean it has low
standards, but it, it does mean
it's much easier to get your
changes in because of time.
You don't have so many people that
it has to go through, or even
just, even if it was just like a
couple of people, it's just people
have to be available to, to
review.
And so, um, so we find like,
especially like with companies,
um, that they like that because it
is easier for them to get their
changes in, um, as well as, uh,
just contributors that, um, that
they don't have to wait so long.
And especially if you're new too,
that, um, you can get changes in
much quicker.
So that, so that's a, that's a big
thing that started from, um, the
early days.
Basically, the governance model
was developed at Berkeley.
And, um, and so they had, if I
remember correctly, they had their
small team of people who did
commit the code, but they had a
lot of other contributors outside
and they would submit their
changes.
And then you'd have the Berkeley
folks, um, who would actually
commit the code to the, the source
tree.
Got it.
Um, talk about, about some of the
main projects that, um, this
foundation has funded.
Um, so like I mentioned, so early
on Java binaries, um, that was big
having that support in there.
And then, um, and Java binaries
moved on to being, uh, open
source, the Java code, Java.
Um, and so we haven't had to step
in for that much.
We do a little support there.
Um, so, um, some of the projects
that we've funded, well, if you
look outside of development, so
we're always focused on like what
software development projects have
we supported.
And we have, um, also stepped in
and put a lot of resources into
this whole advocacy.
So, um, from just providing
literature, handouts, um, how to
guides, um, putting together
online content, getting speakers
to talk about various parts of
FreeBSD, um, that's, I mean, those
are multiple projects, but all
falls under advocacy.
And that's one of the biggest
things that we've grown over the
past few years.
Um, we, my head's like, sort of
this blank right now on like what,
like software projects, but we do
have one, one big project that we
did fund was, uh, what's called
the Linux, Linuxulator.
And, um, and basically what allows
you to do is on FreeBSD, you can
run Linux binaries that, um, so,
and those will run on FreeBSD.
Um, other things coming out of the
project, just the open ZFS or ZFS
support, and we have funded
projects there.
That's been big.
Um, Jails was really the first
containers that you hear about
Docker, but Jails were the first
containers that, um, that was
developed on FreeBSD.
That wasn't something that we did,
but really, um, you know, one of
the significant, um, you know,
features, um, way back when, early
2000s.
How, um, how are, uh, how do
people, uh, get their projects
funded?
What's the process?
So there's a couple things, ways,
uh, we do have a, a CFP or we
have, uh, actually it's a project
proposal application.
And so we have information on our
website on how to submit a
proposal.
So say you have an interest in
implementing something and, um,
but you need funding.
So usually the case is this
person, maybe they have to take
time off of work to do this.
And, uh, so they actually, so they
write up the proposal, like what
is it that they want to do?
What are the outcomes and what's
the timeframe?
And then what's the cost?
And then they submit that to us.
And then what we do is, uh, we
review it internally and then
sometimes we'll actually, uh, send
it to developers to get their
input on, um, is this a project
that would help FreeBSD?
Because we're always looking at
funding projects that really help
further FreeBSD in various ways.
And, uh, you know, it could be
fixing a problem or it could be
implementing a new feature and
really just keeping it, uh,
secure, stable, and, and
innovative.
So, so that's one way that we do
it.
Um, and then the other is that by
working with companies and
understanding, uh, their uses and
their needs, as well as
understanding market trends and
just what's happening out there,
then we also have internal
roadmap.
And, um, and so we look at how do
we fund that work?
And so, and we have software
developers on our own staff and,
um, and so we fund them to work in
various areas.
And we may hire someone to do
specific work or we may just
contract people too.
Do, um, the companies, the
companies that you're doing some
of that work with, do they also
fund the projects as well for you?
Most, most of the funding is, so
most of our funding does come from
companies.
And, um, and so it's, um, it's
almost a hundred percent, uh,
towards our general funds.
So rarely do we take earmark
funding, but we do do that.
So if we have a project, so if a
company wants something and we
feel it's beneficial to FreeBSD in
general, then, uh, if we have the
resources, we'll do that work.
And, uh, but most of the time
companies will give to us because
they know that, uh, the money that
they're giving to us is helping,
um, in these areas I talked about.
So we have people on the security
team, so it's helping with that.
Uh, we have people on staff who
will just step in and fix bugs
right away, uh, whether they're
our bugs or hardware bugs and, uh,
just really having that, the
resources available to get on top
of things quickly.
And so, um, so knowing that the
money is going towards that, I
mean, we, we try to be as
transparent as possible with where
our money is going.
And, uh, we post more high level,
um, state, you know, financial
statements on our website, but we
do try to be, um, open about how
we're spending our money.
And so, so anyway, that's, that's
why that they'll give us money.
We also get money from other
companies that they might not use
FreeBSD, but you know, or they
know that they're benefiting by
supporting us because it helps the
open source ecosystem.
And, um, and also there's
components within FreeBSD that are
used, um, by other companies in
their products or just, um, just
used in however way that they're
using software operating systems.
Are most companies pretty open
about, you know, saying that they
use FreeBSD?
Um, some are, and I, no one is
trying to be secretive about using
it.
It's It's just that that's not
what's important to their product.
So you wouldn't see, you wouldn't
see Sony selling their
PlayStation, you know, saying, oh,
it runs on FreeBSD because it's
the PlayStation that they're
selling.
That's, that's, what's important
using FreeBSD is getting them what
they need in order to create that,
you know, that fabulous product
that everyone wants.
Um, then there's the other
companies like Netflix is really
good.
They're a big advocate of FreeBSD
and they, they've actually given
talks about the high transfer
rates that they achieve on the
internet.
And, uh, which is great.
I mean, cause it helps FreeBSD,
uh, we love to see it and we
really appreciate it when, uh,
when companies are really open
about that and, um, and actually
give talks or write articles about
it.
Talk a bit about just the open
source community in general.
Um, do you, do you notice any
trends or, or personality features
about people that are in that
community?
Um, I mean, I think you could say
that in just tech in general, um,
you know, and, and so I've been
around a lot of different types of
technical, technical people.
Um, open source is, is interesting
cause people are doing open
source.
Most of them are doing those
because they're passionate about
it.
So they're not getting paid to
work on it.
So, um, so like any type of
organization that uses volunteers,
whether it's, you know, like the
humane society, if you love
animals, um, they're there because
they're passionate about it.
And so you see that.
And so, and that's exciting.
And to see people giving their
time, their free time, which is
pretty valuable.
Um, it, it speaks a lot to it.
And so, uh, I do see that a lot in
our community.
I see us as a pretty diverse, uh,
but friendly community.
And when I say diverse, I really
mean in, um, like culture and
backgrounds of people, um,
experiences and cause you'll have
people who they want to get
involved in open source and they
feel like, well, I'm not
qualified.
I'm not technical or I don't write
code, but they want to be
involved.
And they think that they're lesser
because of that.
And I know in our project, um,
like documentation is viewed so
highly that if you come in and you
write documentation, you're viewed
highly.
You're not any lesser because
you're not writing code.
And we have people who create
videos on previous D cause they
love it, but they, they can't
write code or, you know, that's
not their strength.
And, um, and I love seeing these
and, I mean, we could share these
videos that they create.
And, um, and so there's, there's
just so many different ways that
you contribute.
And, and that's in general open
source, but, um, but I do see this
in previous D a lot more as far as
being more equal.
And, um, but also having, um, some
of these original, um, Berkeley
people still in our community.
And when you go to our conferences
that they're available to talk to,
and they love telling stories and
they help, um, bring up these new,
like, you know, younger, usually
it's like it's like younger
people.
Uh, Uh, and, uh, and that's always
exciting to see.
And then when we do have these
conferences, there's so much that
happens there.
And, uh, and I, the biggest thing
is you always have presentations,
which are great.
And that's usually why you go, but
you have hallway tracks and, or
social events and you have, oh,
and we'll always have a hacker
lounge too.
And so you have this opportunity
to work together and come up with
new ideas, or maybe someone has an
idea and now they're sharing that
idea.
And now you have other people who
are interested in working on this.
And so everyone always leaves
these conferences pretty much
exhausted, but really excited.
So, uh, so those are extremely
important.
Talk about the international
aspect of it as well.
The, yeah, it's, I mean, it's,
it's a US focus because like the
foundation, we're a US
corporation, but, and I don't
know, I can't remember what the
breakout is of number of like US
contributors to outside the US,
but you have people from all over
the world and, and, um, you know,
we have lots of people in Europe
and, uh, people in, uh, Ukraine,
uh, Asia, uh, South America who
are contributing to the project.
And, um, and so you have, so you
have different cultures, uh, and,
and it's interesting.
Um, you know, it's, it's
interesting.
I think it's really important for
us to figure out how to work well
together.
And one thing that I learned when
I went to my first European
conference was, um, I'm trying to
remember what country we were in
Malta, maybe.
And we had this guy who, he
organized the European conference
and he asked me what I thought.
And I said, and I told him, I go,
"I'm just exhausted because
everyone has accents and it's so
hard to understand."
And he goes, "but just think most
of these people are native English
speakers and how hard it is for
them."
And after he said that, I was
like, "yeah, I mean, what am I
tired about?" Like I'm, they're
speaking my language to me.
I don't have to deal with it being
my second language.
And so, um, so those are, that was
a real important lesson to me.
And, um, and so, but it's, but
I've, I learned from our community
and I, and I just find it so
interesting, especially when we
have this opportunity to go, we go
to a different country in Europe
every year for a conference and
learning about, um, you know,
their culture and, um, and meeting
local people there.
And that's, uh, that's been really
educational.
So, I mean, so we've gone to like
Malta, Bulgaria, uh, Romania, uh,
Norway, Sweden, Germany, France,
um, you know, England, uh, Japan,
Taiwan, we'll be in Taiwan next
year.
Uh, and so all these opportunities
to meet people from around the
world.
And once, and also once we went
and started doing these virtual
conferences because of COVID, um,
people who normally couldn't
travel, it finally gave them the
opportunity to, to attend some of
these conferences, which was
really nice.
That's terrific.
Did, um, how did COVID impact, uh,
your work?
So, um, so most of us were already
working from home and, um, and so
the impacts were, uh, uh, with our
interns who are working in our
office in Kitchener, Ontario.
And, uh, so we have a, uh, intern
or, um, there's a co-op program
through the University of Waterloo
that we participate in, which has
been great.
And, um, I think we had three
interns and so they're all college
students and they were working in
our office there.
So we have their computer setups
there and they, and not all of
them were from the Kitchener area
either.
And so we had to figure out how we
can set them up to work from home,
get them home and, um, and help
them navigate working online and
having to get their, like their
supervision or mentoring online.
So, um, so that, so that took an
effort to figure out after that,
after once we had finished that
term and had another term, we were
set up then, um, on how to do
that.
And so we're pretty much set up
now to do that.
And then really the other thing
was, was travel.
And what do we do about travel?
Because we had been traveling, uh,
to, like I was saying, around the
world, attending different
conferences, giving workshops,
things like that.
So, so what do we do?
And, um, and what are our
responsibilities as a corporation?
So, so really understanding that
as well as like what were the
government mandates and all that
kind of stuff, understanding that,
understanding to our investments
and what could happen because we,
we try to keep enough money to pay
salaries for one to two years.
And, um, you know, and the stock
market dropped, you know, those
first few days.
And so, um, so it really made me
spend a lot of time understanding
and figuring out putting together
some plans, talking to people.
And also I was talking to people
from other companies, bigger
companies, like, are you
traveling?
Are you going to go to this
conference that's still happening
to give a talk?
And, and so, um, so most of the
people would say, no, our, you
know, companies have travel
restrictions now.
And so, so then it was like, we
could have travel restrictions
too.
And so, so we did do that.
And also, um, making sure
employees felt that, um, they
didn't have to travel, that we
were making sure protections were
in place too.
And even now, um, that in person
conferences are happening again,
um, not everyone is comfortable
traveling yet.
And I know I've been traveling,
but also I'm very careful right
now about getting exposed.
And so I'm one of those who still
wears a mask, but, but that's my
decision.
And, um, if someone on my team is
not comfortable traveling or being
in a big conference setting, then
that's okay.
So, so, um, uh, so we make sure
that, um, you know, that we're,
uh, there's, I don't think there's
anything that we have to do that
we have to actually go and be
physical at, we've done everything
online, which is great.
That's really cool.
Um, you had mentioned, you'd
mentioned, um, that the
originators of FreeBSD are still
very involved in, in the
foundation.
Can Can you talk about some of
those people?
Yes.
And hopefully you'll get their
stories too.
Um, cause there's some great
stories there.
Kirk McKusick, um, he's, he came
from Berkeley.
He was a PhD student when, I
always want to say playing around
with, uh, the Berkeley Annex, but
really, I mean, it was, uh, it was
a product that companies were
using in their, um, doing research
with it.
And so, um, so he's one of the
original people on, um, on BSD,
Berkeley Annex, as well as in
FreeBSD.
But when you talk to him, he'll
say, "well, I wasn't one of the
first, uh, people on FreeBSD
because there was actually a
lawsuit that was happening at the
time and against Berkeley Annex.
And, um, and so for like two
years, I think, um, the developers
from Berkeley, the students
mostly, um, had to, um, had to
focus on that."
And, uh, so FreeBSD had branched
out and from then there was
FreeBSD and NetBSD at the
beginning.
And, um, so some of those folks,
uh, Jordan Hubbard, Rodney Grimes,
some other folks that, um,
hopefully we'll get some, um,
recordings from them to hear their
stories too.
Um, but they were part of FreeBSD
when it first, um, you know,
started out in 1993, which we're
celebrating the 30th anniversary
of this year.
And when did you join the
foundation?
So I joined in 2005.
And so, so since then, like what,
what, um, what kind of changes
have you seen just in the
community and, and, you know,
there's just, I mean, um, it's 18
years.
So what, what, what's changed?
I know it's I know it's a long
time.
Um, I've seen it grow.
Um, yeah, I've seen more people
join.
I've seen more younger people join
too, which has been really cool.
And that's something that we're
really trying to increase too.
So we're learning from them too,
which is great.
Like why, why would you be
interested in, uh, contributing to
FreeBSD or learning about FreeBSD?
The other things from the
foundation perspective is, uh,
we're just funding so much more
work.
We're bringing in a lot more
money.
And like I said earlier on, when I
first joined the foundation, I was
part-time.
And so until I start bringing in
the funds, I stayed part-time,
which I was fine with at the time.
And so as we brought in more
money, then we were able to hire
more people.
So, uh, we brought in, um, Ed
Maust who now oversees all of our
development work, but he, at the
time, uh, he was doing, he was,
uh, doing software development
work himself for us.
We hired a marketing director and
that's when we started providing
all that advocacy material and the
online content and stuff like
that.
And then since, since then, um,
we've hired more software
developers.
We've built our marketing.
Um, and also we're identifying
other, um, positions that would
really help the project.
And I just hired, uh, someone
who's, who just stepped in as our
director of partnership and
research.
And, uh, and that's really gonna
help, um, like nurture and build
these relationships that we have
with companies.
And, um, as well as helping get
more companies, uh, to learn about
previous D and why they should
adopt it.
And so have someone who could
full-time work on that because
that was my job before.
And, and it's just hard to do, to
run the organization and to, um,
you know, be able to to follow up
on, on that type of stuff.
And the research component of that
is really, um, part of it is
policy to where, what should we
get we get involved with?
There's a lot of cybersecurity
stuff going on now.
Um, you know, making sure, um, our
voices or our voice is included in
some of the government, uh,
discussions.
And, um, also what are the trends
that are happening out there and
what should we be involved with?
And, um, as well as looking at
like what research is happening
with freeBSD, there's a a lot of
security work that's happening
with freeBSD.
And so not only spending the time
doing that, but, um, publicizing
that.
And, uh, so users know and
universities know and corporations
know that freeBSD is a really good
solution for like security.
And, um, well with Earth Day
tomorrow, um, yeah, low power
consumption being more
environmentally friendly.
And, uh, so things like that.
So, so we're looking at growing
the team in ways like that, that
helps freeBSD overall.
So that's so how we've grown.
So we have, I don't know, eight,
nine employees now.
Um, and then as far as the growth
of the project, just, um, more
companies using freeBSD or
companies coming out of there
would work too that have been
using freeBSD that we didn't know
about because it's not like we
have this product and we're
selling it.
So we know all the users out there
that are using it.
It's the license allows anyone to
use freeBSD and to make whatever
changes that they want.
And, um, so there's products out
there that are using freeBSD that
we have no idea.
We would love to know, but they
don't have to let us know.
That's not their, that's not their
priority.
So, um, so anyway, so learning
about those uses are interesting
and really helpful.
What is your biggest challenge?
Um, I would say the biggest
challenge that, well, a couple of
things, uh, one is for the
project, one's for us.
So one would be getting the money
that to do this work, to fund the
work.
Cause we, there's, there's so many
things we know we can help with
and we just don't have the
resources to do it.
know we can help with have the
And, uh, we have these
conversations all the time, like,
oh, if we had someone who could
step in to do this, that would be
so beneficial.
And, but we can't, can't do it
cause we don't have the funding.
So really is getting that funding
and having the director of
partnerships will, will really
help that.
Um, and then the other challenge
is within the project that because
it's a volunteer organization is
getting people to do certain
things.
So, you know, if you're a
volunteer and you're working on
here on this project because you
love it, you're passionate about
it.
But maybe there's like some boring
task.
Yeah.
Well, there's a lot of boring
tasks that have to be done.
Yeah.
Do you really want to spend your
time on that?
You want to do the exciting
things.
So, um, so a lot of times it's
hard to find people to do more of
the tactical type of things.
And, um, and that's where actually
we try to step in and help with,
and, um, you know, is, is to, you
know, fill those holes where you
can't get a volunteer, but, um,
but going back to the funding, we
can't always do that.
So I'd say like, those are the two
biggest challenge challenges.
What do you think your leadership,
your leadership style is?
Oh, mine?
Um, I haven't really thought about
that.
Um, I, I'm pretty down to earth
person.
So I'm not, I don't know, pushy
would be the word.
I try to listen to, um, I listen
and watch the staff, you know,
what are their needs?
What am I seeing that maybe they
need help with and, and ask
questions.
And, um, and I really try to make
sure that I think it's really
important to have a good life work
balance.
And, um, and so I make sure that
we're as accommodating as we can
be.
And, and because we are remote and
most people, everyone works from
home, um, it is easier to do that.
I've always loved working from
home.
So, I mean, I love to not having a
commute, just that hour, what can
you do that hour?
Um, and I love being able to just
get up and start working at seven.
So then I, like I was saying, so I
can go for a run or whatever.
And, um, so, so for me, it's
really being available, listening,
um, and asking questions of, you
of, you know, what are your
challenges?
What do you like?
You know, what, what are you doing
that you really don't like?
And, um, and then trying to work
with them on making sure people
are doing what they're interested
in.
And, um, you know, cause they
can't, we have a lot of jobs or
tasks that we have to do that
maybe aren't the things that we
love, just like what I was saying
with the volunteers, but they have
to be done.
So making sure there's a good
balance there too.
Have you had any challenges in
your career, um, being a woman in
sort of a man dominated field?
Um, well, yeah, I have, um, I
mean, even, you know, starting out
in college, um, there weren't that
many women in, who are studying
any, any of those disciplines, uh,
computer science, engineering,
computer engineering, and math.
Cause those were, I think the
areas that I touched on.
Um, but I also found that because
it was such a hard discipline that
we really worked together to
understand things that we had.
Um, I mean, maybe you didn't have
Google back then, but yeah, we had
our own working group that spent a
lot of time together.
And so sometimes, so there might
be six of us and really just
teaching each other concepts, if
someone doesn't understand it.
So maybe I'd have another woman in
there or maybe I'd be the only one
and didn't really matter because
we were all, we all felt like
we're in the same boat.
Yeah.
Just trying to, to swim.
Um, there's definitely companies,
uh, where it was hard, um, from
being discriminated, discriminated
against, um, to, you know, being
in sales, being part of sales and
being at social events, uh, you
have to, I felt like I always had
to to be, um, aware and, um, I
feel like that in life, uh, you
have to be aware of your
surroundings and people around you
anyway.
So I don't think that that's any
different.
Um, but definitely have always
felt that I had to work harder to
do the same thing.
And other people got recognition
where, um, the standards were
definitely lowered.
And what I always found
interesting was when people
started complaining about having
to have that diversity of making
sure you have, yeah, bring more
women.
And I'll use that as an example of
that.
You have to lower standards for
And it's like, I'm thinking, I
think it's the opposite because
I've, I've seen, um, you know, in
many of, um, you know, my jobs
that people were recognized and
praised for not doing a very good
job because there was a lot of
competition.
So I think having more women, um,
does bring in more competition and
it's just really, how do we get
more women first interested in
like STEM fields?
And then the second would be
staying.
So, cause I, I left and, um, and
cause it, it, it, it's hard.
It's not really giving up.
It's like, you look at your life
and you look at what do I want to
do?
What do I want to deal with?
And, um, and so maybe you take a
step back for a little bit.
I got back into tech and, um, and
yeah, things still happen, but,
um, but I'm seeing being back in
tech and going to like these women
and competing conferences from,
uh, like Grace Hopper to, we have,
um, ECM puts on these celebrations
of women competing all around the
world.
And first seeing these students,
seeing the speakers, it's, uh, so
inspirational that there's a lot
of women in STEM and, um, but I
know in operating systems, it is
hard.
And, um, and I, and I don't know
why.
And, um, and so trying to figure
that out and how to make it, um,
you know, attract more people, um,
is, uh, yeah, it's one of the
things that we're trying to work
on.
What do you think has been your,
um, greatest achievement so far in
the field?
Well, so in the field or with the
foundation?
Um, Um, first let's go first in
the field and then, and then the
foundation.
I'd love that.
Um, so I would say, um, that for
me, it's been telling my story to
girls and women at these type of
women competing conferences.
Um, I remember being at, uh,
there's a conference in Europe
called Women Courage and it's put
on by ACM.
It's their, uh, it's their
European women, celebration of
women in computing conference.
And I remember I was staffing a
table and, and so I was there to
promote FreeBSD and trying to
encourage people to consider
contributing or using FreeBSD.
And I had so many women students
come up to me and want to just
talk to me about my background and
my history, sort of like what
we're doing here.
And because a lot of times when
you go to these conferences, you
have, um, you don't have actual
like female, um, engineers there.
You'll have representatives of the
company and usually they're
recruiters or marketing, which is
fine.
Um, and so, but they don't, they
can't tell those types of stories.
And so, uh, so, so much fun, um,
you know, being asked these
questions and then also just how
excited they were about, um, you
know, the potential and the
opportunity.
And, and so really that's what I
feel like is an achievement.
And, um, and it's funny because
usually when you think of an
achievement, you think of
something that you developed and,
you know, and I developed disk
drives.
I want to say that they were great
and, um, implemented new features
and stuff like that.
But really what stands out to me
is that being a role model or
someone who's available to talk
about that.
Yeah, of course you can do it.
And cause I was never told that I
couldn't do it.
And, um, and so it's really
finding, you know, what are you
interested in?
And if you're, and you could be in
tech and still, it doesn't have to
be like you're on a computer and
your mom's face just programming
all day.
It's, it can be so creative and,
um, and you can be outgoing.
And I mean, there's so many
characteristics that aren't part
of the stereotypical software
person that, and so, so if we can
model that and, um, and show more
people who are like that, um, I
think it'll really gain more
interest of, of girls and women in
the field.
Well, that's a great answer, but,
uh, also what about your
achievement at, uh, FreeBSD
Foundation?
Um, Um, so to me, I guess it would
be growing the company because
like I said, I was the first
employee, so we were hardly
anything at the time.
And, um, at the time.
And, um, and now we're this, uh,
team of passionate people about
FreeBSD who can go to companies
and talk to them who go around the
world giving talks of FreeBSD.
A lot of times it's me and, um,
and I'm learning about FreeBSD
and, um, and so what we've been
able to contribute back to the
project.
And by doing that into the world,
because when you look at FreeBSD
as this product, um, I mean,
companies use it and they benefit
from it, but it's this free
operating system that anyone
around the world can use.
And the hardware that it runs on
can be really cheap.
So you can go into, you know,
underdeveloped countries.
And I mean, we can't do this
because we don't have the
resources yet, but other people
could do it.
And so you can, um, teach people
skills that will give them jobs
and, um, you know, and make them
marketable.
And so, so really as, as this free
product, there's so much potential
for it.
That's fantastic.
Um, why do you think it's
important to, to, to be
documenting the history of, of the
field?
Well, I mean, the history of
everything, it's important.
If it's not documented, then you
can change it.
So, right.
I mean, we're, we're, I won't go
into it, but I mean, right.
I I mean, we change history and,
um, and it's interesting.
Um, I mean, it's an interesting
question because when I give my
talks on FreeBSD, I do go over the
history because I think that's
really important.
But you can look at it as like,
well, that's before who cares
about that?
You know, we want to know what,
you know, what's important now or
why it's so great now.
But to me, it always goes back to
the foundation of anything.
So, you know, it can be
multiplication.
So understanding instead of
memorizing tables, understanding
that, you know, yeah.
So it's very Montessori, you know,
if you actually touch it and add
it, you could see it and feel it.
That's foundation and everything
builds off of that.
And so understanding the history,
what really happened and why, and,
you know, and the reasons can can
be different for different people.
Right.
And so, um, so having the stories
available for others, uh, is just
really important.
And yeah, hopefully people find it
interesting.
And I know that my story it's, you
know, at the time I never really
thought like, oh, you know,
there's two women in all my
engineering classes.
Like I'm at the forefront of this.
I never thought of that.
I thought, oh, here's a skill I
can get and I can have job and
financial security and a good
future.
And so I really looked at it like
that.
And it was an opportunity and I
was able, I wasn't limited, like,
you know, when you think of people
like Maria Montessori who wanted,
she wanted to be an engineer and
she could.
They wouldn't allow women to be
engineers.
And I guess that was Italy.
She became a medical doctor and
she was able to do that.
And then what she did was amazing
with her, you know, way, her way
of teaching and developing minds
is so amazing and how they tried
to limit her and she still figured
out a way to do it.
So actually probably because she
became a doctor was because of
that, because she worked with
children and she learned how the
brain worked.
If she was an engineer, she
probably would not have made that
contribution.
And I had never thought of that
before.
It's really interesting.
Yeah, but I think, too, with
things moving so quickly in the
field, it's good to take a moment
and capture a moment in time as
well, you know.
True.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
So one last question.
And that is, if your great, great
grandchild were to stumble on this
recording 100 years from now, what
would you want them to know?
What would you want to say to
them?
If they stumble on this recording,
so they're watching this
recording, that I think I'd want
them to know just that they can do
anything that they want.
And it doesn't mean it's easy.
And usually you have to work hard
towards it.
But if you want it, then go for
it.
And don't let anyone stop you and
tell you you can't do it.
And just believe in yourself.
But also try to find people to
help you, too.
And just try.
And the other thing, too, is just
we learn from our failures.
I mean, you always hear that.
But it's really true.
And if you don't try something,
you won't fail.
And so you lose out on that
learning opportunity.
So when you do fail, it's pretty
horrible at the time.
But you get past it.
And once you get past it, you use
that knowledge to either do better
and or be better or whatever it
is.
So I think that's it.
Just the fact that there's so many
opportunities out there.
And really, try to figure out what
you enjoy and what's your passion.
And try it.
Because really, when you look at
your lifetime, it's a long time.
And you can change.
So if you make a decision to do
something.
And maybe you realize maybe that's
not what you want, that's OK.
That you have time to try
something else.
And what you bring with you is you
gain that experience and
knowledge, too.
So that's what I would say.
And hopefully, I will have great
grandchildren.
That's a great answer.
So So is there anything you wanted
to say that maybe we've skipped
over that you feel is important
that you'd like to get on the
record?
It's funny.
Because to me, when I look back in
my career, I don't see anything
significant that I feel like I
accomplished.
But I also looked at when I was
very career driven when I started
out.
And when I decided to have
children, it really changed my
perspective.
And I think that happens to most
people.
And you realize what's important.
And I think defining that or
understanding that is what should
drive you.
And then you work around it.
And if you're still really, I
mean, I've always wanted to
continue working and working hard
and working in an area that I was
interested in.
But also realizing, too, that
there's other things that are also
as or more important.
And so I feel really good about
what I've done.
And this isn't the end of my life.
And so I see so much more that I
could do, which is exciting, I
think.
I still have ideas going around my
head of things that I would like
to do.
And I'm happy that I'm healthy and
that I feel like I'll be able to
do them.
And I really appreciate the time
that you gave me.
And I look forward to hearing
other stories.
And that's what's exciting, too,
about this project is going back,
is being able to watch some of
these other stories and learning
from these people, too.
Well, thank you so, so much for
sharing your story with us.
Oh, you're welcome.
It has been really fun spending
time just thinking back.
I'm I'm like, what did I do?
Why did I even choose going to
TAC?
Because it was so long ago, right?
It certainly seemed like the right
move.
What's that?
I said, it certainly seemed like
the right move, though.
When you really look back.
Yeah, yeah.
I never regret not taking this
path.
So and I think that's important,
too.